[Applaudissements]
toi ils obligés de se grimer sinon il va
vous allez dire donc les gars l'art est
quand il n'est pas gris mais mais quand
il est comme ça alors se bouchant le nez
encore une qui arrive à la crise mais
pour l'instant pas son nouveau jay-z et
beyoncé c'est tout
[Musique]
tant mieux
[Applaudissements]
c'est les gésiers bios et ne peut pas
les avoir ici alors je ressens polonais
ou hollandais je sais plus mais je rap
français pourquoi je m'étais servi de
cette musique dans lesquels tiers je les
connais je connais cet open me dire que
je prête plus attention à la chronique
de camille combal qu'elle avait
l'impression
je respecte votre amour là je vous en
félicite
et avant de vous quitter on me
communiquent pour sa dernière incruste
de la semaine clément était à la bourre
ça lui arrive du coup bah il a été
obligé de s'incruster tout juste à la
sortie de sa douche en plein direct dans
une émission politique sur une chaîne
régionale
voilà c'est une association s'est
extrait d'un petit film c'est une
association qui propose qui vous propose
d'accueillir des étudiants des lycéens
alors qu'est ce que je disais
sortir
on va les calmer les bases pascal à la
tête du bac apb